Lombardo is set to deliver his first
state of the State address tomorrow in
Carson City 8 news now investigator
David charns joins us live there tonight
for a look ahead and David what can we
expect the governor to talk about
well Sasha will be right around this
time tomorrow six o'clock when Governor
Joe Lombardo will be laying out what he
hopes to accomplish in at least this
first year we're told he will be talking
about the education the economy and
safety of course the governor having
been the head of Metro Police and Clark
County Sheriff for eight years so the
governor has only been governor for
three weeks we all know that but this
address is something every governor of
Nevada does this time of year no matter
how long they have held that title he
will be laying out not only his uh
accomplishments thus far but his goals
for the year ahead of course the
legislative session when laws are made
starts in just two weeks the governor
will be speaking not only to the people
of Nevada when you're watching this at
home but also the 60 or so lawmakers who
are in that room who will be in that
room and talking about what he wants to
do here's what the governor said about
coming together at his inauguration just
earlier this month
indeed ladies and gentlemen as we
balance on the threshold of another
great Nevada era
we've drawn natural strength from the
call of our citizens to meet the future
with unrestrained boldness and inherent
tenacity
Democrats in control of the legislature
there will have to be a lot of
compromise in fact Democrats actually
have a super majority in the State
Assembly and they don't need one
Republican vote to move forward now they
can try to pass whatever they want but
will it get to the desk of Republican
Joe Lombardo that uh will be the big
question this session all of this
happening in the building behind me
eight news now of course you see me here
we are here live we will bring you
everything live tomorrow starting at
four o'clock for now live in Carson City
tonight I'm David charns 8 News Now